je suis très heureux de vous voir
vraiment et je voulais vous dire déjà
avant que vous ne commenciez que vous me
demandiez ce que vous voudriez avoir
pour l'année prochaine je suis très très
heureux de votre saison je vous avais
fait une saison formidable merci
vraiment vous êtes une des meilleures
élèves de la classe de
de ce bureau vraiment tout le monde me
parle de vous je n'ai que des bons
retours même des gens qui ne vous aiment
pas il y en a beaucoup
mais les gens qui vous aiment pas
on l'aime pas mais elle est
exceptionnelle qu'est-ce qui se passe
qu'est-ce que tu veux
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pas incroyable ça n'arrive pas dans les
autres émissions
en train de potasser un sujet un
technicien qui vient vous bouffer le cul
c'est normal
[Rires]
le micro c'est pour parler dedans
merci
[Musique]
vous deviez évaluer votre saison sur une
échelle de 1 à 10
je mettrai 7 7 et demi je mets 9
commencer à réfléchir à votre
[Rires]
client je vais vous poser la même
est-ce que vous avez passé une belle
saison est-ce que vous êtes heureux
alors moi j'ai trouvé que c'était une
saison exceptionnelle j'ai adoré cette
saison particulièrement j'avais moins
aimé l'année dernière j'ai beaucoup aimé
cette saison je l'ai trouvé animé
intense extrêmement varié en fait j'ai
trouvé que c'était vraiment l'ADN de
TPMP cette année encore plus que les
autres années peut-être
pour moi c'est un peu ça faisait un peu
buffet garni quoi all inclusive
c'est-à-dire qu'on avait aussi bien du
Palma du Polska de la Pélissard sort de
mélange comme ça et moi je trouve que ça
ressemble un peu à la société quoi ça
ressemble à à la France en fait et ça ça
m'a plu
écoutez
c'est bleu
alors j'ai quand même des petites
critiques à faire alors c'est pas vous
qui faites
[Applaudissements]
bien compris
[Rires]
merci
souhaitez-vous éventuellement
si vous revenez l'année prochaine pour
moi c'est bien sûr c'est un grand OUI
est-ce que vous avez peut-être des
velléités
[Rires]
de gagner moi plus pour travailler moi
[Applaudissements]
j'ai toujours les recueils de Paul élu
sur moi et je vais vous l'offrir
d'ailleurs après c'est pour moi
ça fait des années moi je suis un petit
rue de lecture
c'est même pas comment ça s'ouvre
d'ailleurs
est-ce que c'est quelque chose qui vous
peut vous traverser l'esprit une
augmentation alors je déteste ce mot
je dirais une revalorisation
franchement
si je dis non c'est un peu démago on va
dire ouais si je dis oui on va dire oh
là là déjà avec tout ce qu'elle touche à
rien faire là on parle non moi
franchement je trouve que ça va c'est
exceptionnel
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non mais après si vous êtes pour ça me
dérange pas de faire plaisir la vérité
je suis pour
et je suis même qui pour parce que je
suis venu
je suis pour Géraldine
Xavier une requête donc là l'argent oui
c'est de côté c'est vulgaire
[Rires]
c'est bon je me suis vidé de ce mot mais
vous aviez autre chose à me demander
[Musique]
[Rires]
si tenter que le chroniqueur ou l'élève
puisse juger le maître et le boss je
vous ai trouvé excellent cette année je
vous ai trouvé
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'étais pas Pau mais vous pouvez non non
plus vous étiez détendu dedans et je
trouvais que
c'est une métaphore
pour moi et je le dis on a arrêté de se
faire des compliments moi Géraldine a
été et je le dis
si je le dis je le dispose vous avez
tous été exceptionnel mais Géraldine a
encore fait une saison incroyable et je
le dis d'autant plus que Géraldine on se
on se frite souvent mais elle est c'est
ça elle a une force de caractère
incroyable et elle passe tout de suite
autre chose elle sait faire la
différence entre ce qu'on se dit dans
l'émission est-ce qu'on se dit en dehors
ce qu'on sait jamais embrouillé en
dehors de l'émission
Daniel aussi on sait jamais brouillé
parce qu'elle ne m'entend pas
mais c'est vrai que voilà et Géraldine
même si on peut avoir des tensions
pendant l'émission Direct elle trace et
c'est pas pour ça que le lendemain elle
va être d'accord avec moi elle va
repartir sur un débat sur lequel on
n'est pas du tout d'accord Géraldine
bravo et cette saison particulièrement
aussi si je peux rajouter un tout petit
truc il y a une très belle énergie
synergie entre nous tous et moi je
retiens aussi mes fous rires avec
Guillaume avec Raymond avec Valérie avec
asta
une position de Castaldi sur un des
sujets donc c'est pour vous merci
[Applaudissements]